Entrez !
Bonjour.
Asseyez-vous, je vous en prie.
Alors, Madame Ducerf c'est ça ?
Oui c'est ça !
Pourquoi vous vouliez me voir ?
Bah en fait voilà :  on vient parce que, avec mon frère, on vient de recevoir le bulletin.
Le bulletin ?
Bah le... le bulletin de salaire de notre mère.
Ah d'accord, bon... Vous savez, elle est pas bien méchante votre maman !
Mais bon, euh... Elle se la... (sifflement)
Branle !
C'est gênant.
Bah non !
Ah si si, c'est gênant.
Ok, c'est gênant.
Ce que je veux dire par là, c'est qu'elle est pas méga au fait de comment se passe le travail en entreprise !
Je me trompe ?
'Faut la voir à l'œuvre...!
Pour le business plan d'octobre, qui est chaud pour le présenter à l'oral ?
Suce-boules !
Nan mais t'es marié !
On te voit.
Tu es... tu es visible.
Ferme ta gueule !
(Bavardages)
(RIRE)
Je vais le défoncer !
Thierry, notre délégué du personnel, est venu se plaindre que vous lui aviez mis une béquille !
Ainsi qu'une frite...
Hoo ! La poucave !
Ah c'est vraiment un suce boules votre délégué !
Vous avez vu comment elle m'a traité monsieur !
C'est vrai que t'es une poucave !
Et un suce boules !
Maman !
Bon alors on fait quoi pour ma mère, là ?
Écoutez, le bulletin de votre mère il est pas si mauvais que ça !
1450 € brut par mois, c'est la moyenne...
Sérieux ?!
Mais oui sérieux, enfin ! Pour ce genre de poste en France, oui !
Allez, vous prenez pas la tête, c'est pas un mauvais élément votre maman !
Avec un peu de persévérance, p't'être qu'à la rentrée prochaine, elle passera au 3ème.
Bon, très bien, ben merci de nous avoir reçu hein, m'sieur Bouchèze !
Mais de rien. Dis au revoir toi !
Au revoir...!
Madame Ducerf !
N'oubliez pas, réunion de bilan sur le mois de novembre demain !
Salle 180 de 9 à 11 !
Oh non, demain on a déjà le dossier Carlo à rendre...!
Mais arrêtez de vous plaindre, Ducerf !
Et ma petite Lucie !
Vous couchez pas trop tard ce soir.
Demain y'a travail.
Dégage, dégage. Ta gueule. Ta gueule.
(CHANTE)
Papa !
Y'a maman qui nous attend, on est garés en bas...
Mais oui c'est bon, oh ça va quoi ! Toujours qu'j'ai rien fait, moi...